Велика контратака. Президент Зеленський наказав збройним силам розробити
план відвоювання окупованих районів півдня України.
Навіщо це робиться так публічно і чи не розкриває це тактичні плани перед ворогом?
На думку Чарльза Купчана, який працював спецпомічником президента США Барака Обами,
коли почалася перша фаза війни на Донбасі і часто бував у Києві та Москві,
вважає, що такий гучний анонс наступу має декілька цілей.
Одна з них - підняття бойового духу і збереження єдності у протистоянні з Росією
як всередині країни, так і серед західних союзників.
Публічне оприлюднення, публічна заява свідчить більше про символізм,
політичне зґуртування сил. Бо якщо ви збираєтесь розпочати наступ,
ви не хочете розповідати про це росіянам. Так?
Ви хочете застати їх зненацька, ви хочете відкинути їх назад, коли росіяни ще не на повну
військову силу закріпилися. Тож те, що це публічно розголошується
як новий наступ української армії, мені чітко зрозуміло, що цільовою аудиторією
є не росіяни, а українці та міжнародна спільнота.
Зрештою, певною мірою це може бути спрямовано і проти російських військових
і російської громадськості в тому сенсі, що вже відомо про невдоволення в російських рядах,
невдоволення серед російських еліт і російської громадськості.
І тому один із можливих посилів, який робить Зеленський, полягає в тому,
що, мовляв, не думайте, що боротьба закінчилася. Не думайте,
що ви досягаєте своїх цілей. Ми повертаємося до вас.
Ще одна з цілей публічного оголошення наступу - тримати російські війська у напрузі,
відтягнути їхні сили з Донбасу, а також, на думку деяких військових оглядачів,
відвернути увагу Кремля від планів нового наступу на Київ та наземного вторгнення
з території Білорусі. Опитані DW експерти вважають, що битва за Донбас
буде довгою і важкою, тоді як можна очікувати відносно швидкого успіху
в контратаці на півдні України.
Є дві речі, які грають на користь українців. Одна з них - це скоординована кампанія
нанесення ударів по складах російських боєприпасів, яка допоможе з часом
вирівняти умови гри в цій дуелі далекобійної артилерії.
Ще одна ключова перевага полягає в тому, що на цих окупованих територіях
є дуже активний український опір. І тому поєднання дуже добрих розвідувальних даних,
які надають українцям західні партнери, зокрема США та Великобританія,
партизани та їхня діяльність в російському тилу, надання координат для різних цілей,
а також нові далекобійні системи - це потужна комбінація.
Ми бачили це останніми днями, коли російські склади боєприпасів
перетворювалися на попіл.
Це кадри ударів Збройних сил України по складах боєприпасів у Новій Каховці 11 липня.
За останні два тижні подібних атак було завдано щонайменше
по десяти об'єктах російських військ на окупованих територіях.
Окупанти вже дуже добре відчули, що таке сучасна артилерія.
І у них не буде безпечного тилу ніде на нашій землі, яку вони окупували.
З такою точністю бити вглиб території противника українським військовим
дозволяють американські ракетні системи залпового вогню HIMARS.
Ця зброя, вважають експерти, дає значну перевагу українській армії
і значно сприятиме відвоюванню півдня України.
Ракети, випущені з системи HIMARS, можуть вражати цілі на відстані до 70-80 кілометрів.
Але перш за все, це їхня точність. Ця артилерія дуже точно вражає заздалегідь
встановлені цілі. У цьому відношенні можна говорити про переломний момент.
До того ж, українські збройні сили дуже добре знають свої цілі.
Це їхня власна країна, і вони чудово знають, де знаходяться, наприклад,
склади боєприпасів, які вони атакують за допомогою цієї системи.
Найближчим часом американці поставлять в Україну ще чотири такі системи
у рамках нового пакету допомоги у розмірі 400 мільйонів доларів.
Таким чином, в арсеналі ЗСУ буде вже 12 "хаймарсів". Крім цього,
європейські партнери відправили Києву 18 систем M270 MLRS,
12 французьких самохідних установок СAESAR та стільки ж Панцергаубиць 2000
німецького виробництва. І це далеко не повний перелік поставленої техніки.
Схожих сучасних систем в арсеналі армія РФ не має.
Але перевага в кількості озброєння, як і раніше,
залишається на боці Москви, зазначають експерти.
У Росії справді закінчуються сучасні системи озброєння.
Але вона має величезний арсенал старих систем, які застаріли
на 30, 40 або навіть 50 років, але їх у Росії повні склади, і РФ, звісно,
використовуватиме ці старі системи озброєнь. Це не дуже добра новина для України,
оскільки це означає, що Росія все ще має достатню кількість боєприпасів,
а також що вона завдаватиме ще більших збитків мирному населенню.
Для переходу в контрнаступ в української армії не достатньо "хаймарсів"
- потрібно також інше озброєння, вважають експерти, зокрема танки
і бойові машини піхоти. Західні партнери поки що не постачають
це у належній кількості, а про деякі види наступальної зброї переговори ведуться дуже туго.
Якщо українці отримають достатню кількість зброї від Заходу,
вони, ймовірно, зможуть продовжувати обороняти велику частину країни
з дуже великою ймовірністю успіху. Питання в наступному:
чи отримає Україна достатньо зброї? Чи зможе Україна створити
достатньо бойових підрозділів та бойової могутності, щоб здолати росіян на окупованих територіях?
Без серйозних і злагоджених поставок західної зброї в Україні
буде затяжна війна і фактор часу в цьому випадку може грати на руку Росії.
З іншого боку, військові оглядачі стверджують, що росіян протверезила
боєздатність та рішучість українських збройних сил, і вони зазнали
дуже значних втрат у живій силі й техніці.
За словами експертів, ця війна - це частково питання битви волі,
а не просто битви військової сили, тому Зеленський і заявляє публічно
про контрнаступ, мотивуючи і надихаючи українське суспільство
і деморалізуючи російська війська на окупованих територіях.